[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبدا اكل معتاد بالعناوين
مراجعتنا امريكيه لتهديدات ايران البنت
يؤكد على مواجهه الميليشيات التابعه لطارا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دوله محوريه
رئيسه وزراء العراقي يؤكد للعربيه ان
السعوديه دوله محوريه العراق للتكوين
النظام الاقليمي المستقر معه
انتقادات لسوق المحاماه في السعوديه رفض
لممارسات الوصايه ودعوات لتطوير اداء
المحامي
في الرابعه
استعدادات مكثفه لموسم العمره في رمضان
وثمانيه ملايين معتمر قدموا للسعوديه خلال
سبعه اشهر
والشرقيه تشهد اول معرض للكتاب 100
الناشرين والفعاليات الثقافيه في اكسبو
دارك
نبدا من هذا الخبر العاجل حيث افادت وسائل
الاعلام من بريطانيه بسماع عدوي انفجار
قوي في ليستر وقالت ان هذا الصوت لم تعرف
سببه حتى اللحظه فيما تداولت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فيديو مسجل من كاميرا
مراقبه تلفزيونيه يوثق ما قيل انه لحظه
دويه الانفجار القوي
من لندن تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه عروب
عبد الحق عروب مرحبا بك هل اتضحت اسباب
هذا الصوت وهذا الانفجار
مرحبا مرحبا بك يعني هذا الانفجار هو يبدو
انه انفجار صوتي وليس انفجارا على الارض
كان هناك تغريده من
يعني الحساب الرسمي لشرطه
وهي تقول بان هذا الصوت يعني تلقت العديد
من الاتصالات والعديد من القلق على هذا
الصوت المدوي الذي سمعه سكان المنطقه قالت
يعني قالت الشرطه
بالحسابها الرسمي انه لا شيء ليس هناك اي
شيء يدعو الى القلق
وهذا كان التفسير هذه كانت يعني
الاجابه الرسميه من الشرطه طبعا هذه
المدينه يعني تقع هي في الشرق من انجلترا
في شمال العاصمه البريطانيه لندن سمع هذا
ذوي هذا الانفجار الصوتي ليس فقط في بلده
لاستر شير وانما في المدن والقرى المحيطه
بها بحسن ما يتم كما ذكرت يعني على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هذه المنطقه يعني من
اطلاله عليها هناك عدد من يعني القواعد
العسكريه التي تكون في هذه المنطقه لا
نعرف نحن الاسباب لهذا الانفجار الصوتي
الذي وقع وليس هناك تفسير بعد من الشرطه
يعني
شيء يدعو الى القلق لذلك نحن ننتظر لنرى
اذا كان سيكون هناك تفسير اكبر لهذه لهذه
لهذا الانفجار شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
مراسله العربيه عرب عبد الحق
والى الملف الايراني حيث اكد مسؤول في
البنتاجون ان العمل جار على مواجهه مجموعه
واسع مما وصفه بالتهديدات المرتبطه بايران
ومواجهه الميليشيات المواليه لها التي
تهدد القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه
المسؤولون الامريكيه قال لنيران تتعاون مع
روسيا وهذا سيكون له مضاعفات سيئه على
المنطق وتحدث المسؤول في البنتاجون عن
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي الى المنطقه
لبحث مواجهه ايران ودعم اوكرانيا
وفي ذات سياق ناقش رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للجيش الامريكي مارك ميلي خلال
رحلته الى اسرائيل مع كبار المسؤولين
العسكريين في البلاد ناقش تهديدات ايران
ومنعها من صنع اسلحه نوويه ومن جانبيه كاد
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوافق على اهميه
التعاون الدولي لمنع ايران من الحصول على
الاسلحه النوويه واصفا لاجتماع الذي
تناولت تهديدات ايران لاسرائيل والمنطقه
ككل بالمهم
مراسل العربيه حسين ضد حسين مرحبا بك حسين
ما هي الاسباب التي تدعو الانمارك ميلي
وكذلك
الى زياره اسرائيل في هذا التوقيت الذي
يتزامن كذلك مع زياره المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه رافايل جروسي الى طهران
تحيه لك يا خالد هناك من المحللين من
يربطون هذه الزياره والتصعيد في الشرق
الاوسط والتقدم الحاصل في الملف الايراني
بعد الكشف عن ان
لا نتمكن تقسيم اليورانيوم بنسبه 84%
يمكن
ها انها خلال 12
شهرا
عام 2018 ولكن المسؤول
في حدث البارحه الى
الموجوده الان لدى بالنسبه للرئيس
الامريكي
حتى الان عن خيار عسكري وان لم يستبعدوه
قال ان من مهمه وزير الدفاع الامريكي هو
وضع الخيارات الاخرى امام الرئيس الامريكي
ومنها الخيار العسكري ولكن هذه الزياره
كما اعلن بشكل غير مباشر هذا المسؤول الى
المنطقه الى ثلاث دول هي مصر والاردن
واسرائيل وربما يكون هناك دوله رابعه
راب واضافه الى ملفات عديده منها موضوع
الاستقرار والامن في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
ولمصر والاردن دور محمد في ذلك
وايضا الاوكرانيه ولكن بطبيعه الحال عندما
سئل او يسال المسؤولون الامريكيون عن
موضوع الخيارات الاخرى للتعامل مع ايران
يتحدث المسؤول عن سنيرو سيناريوهات جديده
للتعامل او لمواجهه ايران التي تمثلها من
خلال نظامها للمليشيات المواليه لها
بالسلاح والتدريب ومن خلال تهديد في البحر
والمر وايضا بالنسبه
الجديده
خالد اعتمد بحسب ما قيل لنا
موضوع التدخل
الاستراتيجيه عبر المحيط الى المنطقه
منطقه اذا كان هناك مواجهه عسكريه بدل
ارسال قوات كبيره من حاملات طائرات واركان
القاذفات 152 مثلا وايضا بالنسبه للطائرات
العسكريه الموجوده في المنطقه هذا سيناريو
الولايات المتحده خلال مناورات عسكريه
اجرتها مع اسرائيل في يناير الماضي تقوم
على الانتشار العسكري السريع والقصف
والخروج من المنطقه ولكن كما يشدد
المسؤولون الامريكيون دائما الخيار الاول
بالنسبه للرئيس الامريكي والاهم حتى الان
هو الخيار الدبلوماسي لوضع حدود لهذا
الملف من التقدم الذي اجرته ايران وايضا
التخصيب كانوا يريدون التصعيد في هذا
الموضوع
دائما جميع المتحدثين خالد الى موضوع
اول
ا معهم في حلول عسكريه اخرى شكرا على هذه
الافاده منها
وفي الملف النووي الايرانيه ايضا شدد
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافائي خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
رئيسي منظمه طاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي في طهران على ضروره ان تكون ايران
واضحه وشفافه بشان برنامجها النووي وقال
جروسي ان العلاقات بين الوكاله الدوليه
والطيران يجب ان تؤدي الى بناء الثقه ويجب
ان يكون هناك حوار دائم ومعمق
وكد ان الوكاله الدوليه ملتزمه بالمعاهدات
التي تعطيها الحق في تفتيش المنشاه
النوويه
مجموعتان من الامور المهمات تجري حولها
المحادثات والمعيرا هناك توقعات كبيره
بشان عملنا المشترك من اجل المضي قدما في
القضايا التي تعمل ايران والوكاله على
توضيحها وتقديم ضمانات موثوقه بشان
برنامجا نووي اما المجموعه الثانيه مهمه
للغايه وتتعلق بالتعاون العلمي التقني
المستمر في التعامل مع ايران
اكد رئيس وزراء العراق محمد شيع السوداني
في مقابله مع العربيه على رفض بغداد لاي
اعتداء على الحدود العراقيه وقال رئيس
وزراء العراق ان بغداد رفضت الاعتداءات
التركيه والايرانيه باجراءات رسميه واضاف
السوداني الا تواجد لداعش في المدن
العراقيه ولا عوده للطائفيه في البلاد
وكذا ان هناك مباحثات مع طهران وانقره
بشان ملف المياه ولا دول الجوار لجات الى
سياسات مائيه على خلاف الاتفاقات الملزمه
وفيما يتعلق بملف الفساد بالعراق قال ان
انه لا خطوط حمراء في مكافحه الفساد واشار
الى فئه من المسؤولين والموظفين في البلاد
محميه من القوه السياسيه وهو من يقترح
ويجد
الحدود
حول العلاقات مع السعوديه كذا السوداني ان
السعوديه دوله محوريه وشريك استراتيجي
للعراق معتبرا انما بين البلدين من ثقل
عربيا واسلامي يمهد الطريق لتشكيل مرتكز
لنظام اقليمي مستقر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دوله محوريه
وشريك استراتيجي للعراق ما بيننا من
الثقل والوجود على المستوى العربي
والاسلامي وكذلك ما لدينا من ثروات وموارد
كلها مزايا ممكن ان تؤسس للعراق والسعوديه
ان يكون يكون
محور
[موسيقى]
ومرتكز لنظام اقليمي مستقر
واضاف رئيس الوزراء العراقيه انه اتفقا مع
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اثناء لقاء جمعهما على جدول اعمال
للزيارات وعلى تفعيل الشركات بين البلدين
كان لي لقاء مع السموم ولي العهد في
الرياض على هامش القمه العربيه الصينيه
وتحدثنا بوضوح واتفقنا على جدول اعمال
لثلاثه سنوات يبدا بزيارات واجتماعات
وتفعيل الاشتراكات
وبالفعل بدات الزيارات تستقبلنا السيد
وزير الخارجيه السعودي وكذلك ننتظر وزير
التجاره رئيس المجلس التنسيقي ومؤخرا
زارا وزير الداخليه العراقي الرياض وتم
التوقيع على مذكره للتفاهم والتعاون
الامني هي الاولى منذ عام 1983 هذا واحد
من اهم اشكال التعاون والعلاقه المستقبليه
رفع مستمره فيها بعد قليل انتقادات لسوق
المحاماه في السعوديه رفض لممارسات
الوصايه ودعوات لتطوير اداء المحامي
اهلا بكم من جديد تحديات كبيره وانتقادات
مستمره لواقع المحاماه في السعوديه تلك
الانتقادات تناولت اتجاه بعض المحامين
للوصايه والوعظ بعيدا عن الادوار الرئيسيه
للمهنه زميل سعود الخلف يشخص لنا جزءا من
واقع سوق المحاماه في السعوديه
تواجه مهنه المحاماه في السعوديه عده
تحديات منذ سنوات مضت وسط انتقادات من قبل
البعض حول اداء بعض المحامين في الكثير من
القضايا داخل السعوديه وجود المكاتب
الاجنبيه في المملكه هو شيء ايجابي يرفع
سوق المنافسه ويفتح مجال العمل للسعوديين
النقطه الثانيه ان
المكاتب السعوديه مؤهله غير مؤهله مؤهله
ومؤهله على مستوى عالي تعاون بين المكاتب
مكاتب المحاماه وفتح مكاتب محاماه اجنبيه
مهم جدا
ويعود ايجابا على سوق العمل
والتطور العدلي الانتقادات طالت بعض
الممارسات التي يشهدها سلك المحاماه من
توجه للوعظ والوصايه والبعد عن ممارسه
الدور الرئيس للمهنه وهو الترافع وتوعيه
المدعين بما لهم وما عليهم فيما ذهب اخرون
الى ان حداثه التنظيم الفعلي لمهنه
المحاماه في السعوديه والذي قبل واحد
وعشرين عاما فقط ساهمت في انتشار مثل تلك
الممارسات حل القضايا في الصلح او
بالتسويات هذا معمول لي في اكبر دول
العالم مش في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فمرور القضيه بمراحل التسويه وكثير من
القضايا بالذات في امريكا يعني اوروبا
قضيته حل خارج المحاكم بطريقه التسويه
بشكل كبير وهذا يعتبر على فكره من كفاءه
وشطاره المحامي مش مش تقليل من من عمله او
من كفاءته وزاره العدل السعوديه قررت
السماحه مؤخرا بالحصول على ترخيص بمزاوله
المهنه لمكاتب المحاماه الاجنبيه من خلال
تقليب طلب عبر بوابه الخدمات العدليه
الالكترونيه ناجز التابعه لوزاره العدل
المكاتب حقيقه الموجوده الان في دخلت في
عمليه اعاده غربله كبيره جدا لواقعها
بعضها قرر الخروج بعضها قرر التطوير
وبعضها قرر مواءمه واقعه مع الق الجديده
وهدف الحقيقه سيكون له انعكاس كبير جدا
ايجابي على واقع العمل القانوني وجذب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتشير احصاءات رسميه الى زياده
ملحوظه في اعداد المنتسبين لمهنه المحاماه
من السعوديين حيث وصل عدد المحامين المرخص
لهم اكثر من 14 الف محامي منهم
11,355 محاميا
2,833 محاميه جميعهم يمثلون عددا من
التخصصات القانونيه من جده صعود الخلف
العربيه
استديوهاتنا من الرياض المحامي ماجد قارب
دكتور حياك الله معي
تواجدك معنا خليني اسمع اول شيء التعليقك
ما زالت الانتقادات مستمره حول مهنه
المحاماه في السعوديه ما رايك في هذا
الكلام وفي اكثر من مجال بالمجمل حقيقه
نتفق معهم فيها اللي سبب بسيط جدا انه
نظام المحاماه منذ ان صدر من اكثر من 20
سنه تحدث عن فتره انتقاليه مدتها خمس
سنوات لتعديل وتطوير النظام حتى يتمكن من
دفع المهم المهنه الى الامام وانتشالها من
السلبيات التي كانت تشوبها حتى الان حقيقه
لم تعدل اهم هذه التعديلات للفتره
الانتقاليه الا منذ شهور بسيطه جدا وهذا
ما يحسب لوزاره العدل
بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى مؤخرا
ولذلك تنظيم المحاماه تنظيم مهنه المحاماه
الذي صدر منذ ما يقارب عشره سنوات لم
يتمكن من انتشال المهنه من العشوائي ان صح
التعبير الى ما نتطلع اليه في اطار الرؤيه
وما تستحق المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
قضاء منسوب الى الشريعه الاسلاميه والشارع
الاسلامي الحنيف ان تكون في مستوى مهني
رائع جدا بالرغم من كون ان التنظيم ينص
انه الهدف الاساسي له هو تمكين المحامين
من الالمام بمهنيه مهنه المحاماه والالمان
بها والعمل على وفق اسسها ولكن وجود
النظام الذي لم يعدل الا منذ شهور بسيطه
ليش لم يعدل لمده شهور يعني
ولا يمكن ان نقول انه حتى التجربه حديثه
يعني 21 سنه مش فتره قصيره
من اهم عيوب النظام القديم انه كان يسمح
لكل من يستطيع ان يحصل على وكاله بالترافع
من الام والغير متعلم والمحامي والمهندس
والطبيب ورجل الشارع العادي واي واحد عنده
وكاله يستطيع ان يترفع هذا منع وبالتالي
الاساس هو انعكاس ذلك تنظيم على
الثقافه الحقوقيه للمجتمع حتى يستطيع ان
يعلم ان كلمه محكمه تعني فقط قاضي ومحامي
وليس اي واحد يروح زي دعوه وكيله بخلافه
التعديل التنظيمي العام لمهنه المحاماه
اليوم يستطيع ان يحقق اهدافه بعد التعديل
الذي حصل على نظام المحاماه يضاف الى ذلك
حقيقه صدور وثيقتين مهمه جدا اكثر من
رائعه ستدفع المهنه تجاه ما نحن نعيش
اليوم من تطور في جميع قطاعات ومناحي
الدوله وهي لائحه قواعد سلوك المحامين
وهذه ستضع مبادئ اخلاقيه قبل ان تكون
مهنيه على اصحاب المكاتب والمحامين
المرخصين حتى يتمكنوا من اداء مهمتهم بشكل
احترافي ومهني سليم وستؤدي الى تعريفهم
بمعنى كلمه المهنيه لانها ليست مجرد رخصه
ليس كل من حصل على رخصه مهني بقدر ما انه
يتطلب ان يتحول المرخص الى مهنيه كامله
ليست فقط في ممارسه امام القضاء ستنعكس
ايضا على الثقافه الحديبيه
ما تقوم به الان وزاره العدل حقيقه في
الاسابيع والشهور الاخيره رائع جدا كيف
اهمها من يطلع على لائحه الترخيص في مكاتب
المحاماه الاجنبيه يجد كثير من المفردات
المهنيه فيها ستفرض على مكاتب المحاماه
الاجنبيه الى توطين مهنه الاستشارات
والمحاماه بشكل عالي الكعب ان صح التعبير
يعني بالتشبيه الرياضي هنكون مستخدمين
لكريستيانو رونالدو في المحاماه بهذه
الطريقه الرائعه وبالتالي هذا الرفع من
حجم الاعمال التي تؤديها مكاتب المحاماه
الاجنبيه في المملكه ستؤدي لهم بالضروره
اجبارا الى تدريب وتاهيل المحامين
السعوديين وبالتالي سيكون هناك تنافس مهني
على ارض الواقع بعيدا عن كونها المكاتب
الاجنبيه كانت نحصل على الاعمال وتؤديها
في خارج المملكه وبالتالي سيكون عندنا
ايلا ترسيخ وتوطين وتثبيت كثير من مبادئ
وقيم التعليم والتدريب للمحامين وبالتالي
سنرى قريبا جدا اجيال سعوديه قويه جدا
متمكنه من المستوى العالي لمهنه المحاماه
وايضا
تفضل ايضا ستؤدي الى
التعديلات الجديده في المنظومه القضائيه
بشكل عام التي بدات ترسخ لمبدا العداله
الوقائيه والدور الكبير والخطير والغير
مسبوق لمحاكم التنفيذ الى تفعيل ما يسمى
العداله الوقائيه وهذه ستعزز مكانه الدوره
الاستشاري للمحامي ومكاتب المحاماه على
حساب الثقافه الحقوقيه الضعيفه للمجتمع
السعودي بشكل عام بشكل عام وايضا مجتمع
الاعمال انه المحامي فقط مرتبط بالقضيه
والمحكمه بينما في العالم كله الشق
الاستشاري حقيقه 90% من حجم اعمال كبرى
مكاتب المحاماه العالميه ولذلك احنا
مركزين في العشره في الميه وهو دور ثانوي
اذا مقرن بقوه وحجم اعمال مكاتب المحاماه
الكبيره التي يجب ان يتوجه اليها المحامي
السعودي ومجتمع الاعمال السعودي انت شايف
انه هذه اللوائح الجديده يعني
حتقلص او حتى تقضي على حاله الفوضى
والعشوائيه الموجوده يعني كم فتره زمنيه
يمكن نقول بانه هذه اللوائح كفيله في حال
وجدت المتابعه والمراقبه ان تقضي على هذه
الحاله ان طبقت بما يجب ان تطبق عليه نعم
انا اعتقد انه في خلال ثلاثه الى خمسه
سنوات سنكون في واقع احترافي عالي جدا
لانه اليوم الحياه الالكترونيه التي بكره
مؤتمر العداله السعودي سيركز في الحديث
عنها مع قواعد السلوك المهني مع التعديل
الذي حصل على نظام المحاماه مع الاسلوب
الجديد
ليش مو اقل من كده يعني هذه مساله فيها
ثقافه تغيير الثقافات ما ياتي ما بين يوم
وليله الافكار الصوره الذهنيه يعني العالم
العربي كله متاثر بالافلام العربيه عن دور
المحامي اللي فيه كثير جدا من العشوائيه
والشطاره والفهله وانصح التعبير البلطجه
كل هذه الامور حقيقه عشان تسحبها من دهنيه
المجتمع تحتاج الى تغيير من الوقت وتحتاج
الى وقت مهم جدا واعتقد انه يعني هيئه
المحامين مشكوره في في سبيلها انت ان
تتمكن من القيام باعمال يتلقاها مجتمع
الاعمال والمحامين بصوره ايجابيه افضل انا
بسالك عن نقطتين بشكل سريع دكتور ماجد
تفضل احداها انه الان هناك من يرى بانه
يتم انتحال صفه المحامي وخاصه في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من خلال معرفات واسماء
او غيرها من الامور ويقومون باعمال هي
اعمال المفترض ان تكون مقصوره على مهنه
المحاماه الاستشارات القانونيه كتابه
المذكرات وغيرها هذه كيف ممكن يعني يتم
معالجتها والامر الاخر اللي ذكرته انت في
مقال لك ايضا انه انه هناك مجموعه من
التحديات القانونيه التي تعيق التنميه
وتحقيق مستهدفات الرؤيه الحديث عن انه
معظم الشركات العامه المدرجه في السوق
الماليه ليس باداره قانونيه وكثير من
الجهات الحكوميه حتى من القطاع الخاص لم
تصل الى مثل هذه الثقافه على الرغم من من
انه مرتبطه تحقيق مستهدفاتها هذه الرؤيه
بمعالجه مثل هذه الثغرات صحيح دكتور
نظام المحاماه بالرغم من انه كان يتحدث
على انه هناك عقوبه سجن وغرامه ماليه لمن
ينتحل صفه المحامي كان هناك ثغره قانونيه
في النظام تسمح لاي شخص انه ياخذ ثلاثه
قضايا بدون رقابه ولا تنسى انه انعدام
الربط الالكتروني بين المحاكم خلت الثلاثه
تصير 3000 وبالتالي
اصبحت مهنه الترافع امام القضاء مهنه لمن
ليس له مهنه وبالتالي هذا سبب شيوع وجود
منتحل صفه المحامين
والكل يتحدث عن علاقات وشبهات واشياء من
هذا القبيل في العهود السابقه وبالتالي
هذه الثقافه لا تستطيع ان تعيبها لانه كان
واقع عشوائي نعيشه اليوم هذا الانعدام
المهنيه والاحترافيه في العمل يجعل حتى
الجهات الحكوميه مع كل الاحترام لها بما
في ذلك الوزارات والهيئات لما تيجي تقيم
الادارات القانونيه اليوم في دراسه رائعه
جدا كاشفه للحقائق صدرت من معهد الاداره
العامه تحدثت عن مواقع الادارات القانونيه
في الاجهزه والوزارات الحكوميه كلها كانت
النتيجه حقيقيه احنا كمهنيين نعرفها تكاد
تكون صفريه من حيث المستوى والاداء ولانه
انعدام التاهيل اي واحد يكون في اي اداره
ويترقع عبر الزمن والتاريخ دون ان يكون في
هناك رقابه مهنيه احترافيه
لمستوى اداؤه معقول تيجي تلاقي واحد خريج
اي شيء تلاقيه مثلا في وزاره متخصصه معينه
تحتاج الى خبرات معينه في الاتحاد الدولي
المحامين عندنا
التخصصات القانونيه 55 تخصص قانوني
وبالتالي احنا نحتاج الى انه نفهم هذه
الثقافه ونفهم ان هناك تخصصات قانونيه وفي
داخل كل عنوان قانوني هناك تخصصات فرعيه
كثيره عشان كده بقول لك نحتاج الى ثلاثه
خمسه سنوات من العمل الجاد اللي اليوم
تقوده باحترافيه كبيره وزاره العدل
السعوديه شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه يا دكتور
ماجد قارون شكرا المحامي شكرا مره اخرى
شكرا
بالتزامن مع ازدياد اعداد المعتمرين
مقارنه بما كانت عليه قبل جائحه كورونا
كشفت مصادر للعربيه ان السعوديه استقبلت
منذ بدء موسم العمره الجاريه الذي انطلق
في محرم الماضي نحو ثمانيه ملايين معتمر
بمختلف انواع التاشيرات حول الاستعدادات
لموسم العمره في شهر رمضان اعلنت رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين عن خطتها التي تضمنت توفير
اكثر من 20 الف من الكوادر البشريه
استعدادا لاستقبال وخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
ينضم الينا من جده الدكتور عمرو المداح
وكيل وزاره الحج والعمره لخدمات الحجاج
والمعتمرين دكتور عمرو مرحبا بك هل
الاستعدادات تختلف في موسم العمره هذا
العام عن الموسم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا موسم العمره
هذا السنه احنا نتحدث عن اعداد يعني
الاعلى على مر السنوات الماضيه والموسم
هذا يختلف عن الاعوام السابقه نحن نعود
بعد الجائحه باعداد كبيره الان يعني اذا
شاهدنا القنوات والبث المباشر
للمسجد الحرام سنجد ان اعداد المعتمرين
المتواجدين في الحرم بشكل كبير على طوال
اليوم فاحنا الاستعدادات يجب ان تكون على
اكمل وجه خاصه انه مازلنا لم ندخل في شهر
رمضان ونرى الاعداد الكبيره المتواجده
حاليا في المملكه وبالتالي يجب ان تعتمد
على ماذا هذه الاستعدادات الان
طبعا
من العاملين في الاستقبال على المباشره
والخدمات
الارضيه
وكذلك على عمليه التنظيم في التنقلات
بالحافلات وخلا والاستقبال في المطارات
الجزء الثاني والاهم هو عمليه التنسيق
والتكامل في الخطط بين جهات المختلفه سواء
حكوميه او قطاع خاص لانه رحله اداء العمره
ورحله زياره المسجد الحرام تتكون من
مجموعه من العمليات المترابطه والمتشعب
فبالتالي التنسيق والموانعه على خاصه مع
تواجد اعداد كبيره بهذا الشكل في غايه
انتم حاطين رقم معين مستهدف او متوقع في
موسم العمره هذا العام خصوصا مع التمرين
الخارج
نتوقع مع نهايه شهر رمضان هذا العام باذن
الله ان نقارب تسعه مليون معتمد باذن الله
الزياده يعني بمعدل مليونين تقريبا او اقل
من ذلك
اقل اقل من ذلك ولكن الاعداد يعني لا يخفى
عن الجميع المشاهد رمضان من اكثر الاشهر
التي يقدم فيها المعتمرين من الخارج مع
متغير رئيسي هذه السنه هو وجود تاشيره
السياحه كذلك والتسهيلات التي حصلت في
مختلف انواع التاشيرات فاصبح الحصول على
التاشيره
بغايه السهوله مما يساعد في قدوم اعداد
كثيره كذلك
بالتجهيزات المعدل الاستقبال هذا العدد
خاصه في شهر رمضان الى اي مدى ايضا تختلف
التجهيزات الان يعني مختلف الجهات
الحكوميه تبحث عن اتاحه الفرصه
المناسبه للمعتمرين القادمين من خارج
لزياره المناسك واداء العمره
وزياره المسجد النبوي الشريف فهذا يتطلب
عمليات تنظيميه من الدخول الى المسجد
الحرام والمواعيد المتاحه لذلك دائما تمنح
الاول الاولويه للقادمين من الخارج من
المعتمرين والزائرين للوصول لاداء العمره
وكذلك يتم ترتيب التنقلات بالحافلات
والحركه داخل المنطقه المركزيه بما يتيح
الوصول باذن الله بكل يسر وثلاثه العمليات
التنظيميه تختلف باختلاف الموسم وخاصه مع
قرب شهر رمضان والكثافه العدديه الكبيره
المتوقعه كذلك من داخل المملكه لكن نحرص
باذن الله على ان تكون كافه الخدمات
والاستعدادات
على اكمل وجه بما يمثل الصوره التي نسعى
لها في خدمه المملكه بدون رحمه دكتور
تجديد والتطوير يمكن من اهم الامور اللي
ساهمت في انجاح يعني رحله الحاج وكذلك
المؤتمر هي المساله التقنيه والتكنولوجيه
بالتالي الى اي مدى تخدمكم وهل نتوقع ايضا
تطوير في في تقديم هذه
الخدمه للمعتمر خلال فتره القادمه
بكل تاكيد التحول الرقمي هو الحصان الاسود
الذي يراهن عليه مختلف الجهات سواء داخل
المملكه وخارجها لعمليه تطوير الخدمه
تطوير الخدمات المقدمه لضيوف الرحمن يعتمد
بشكل كبير على التحول الرقمي الذي تشهده
المملكه وتشهد منظومه ضيوف الرحمن بشكل
خاص لذلك اطلقت الوزاره وزاره الحج
والعمره بالشراكه مع وزاره السياحه وتحت
مظله برنامج خدمه الضيوف الرحمن
النسك ونسك هي لهويه التسويقيه الان التي
نسعى من خلالها لتسهيل وتقديم كافه
القدمات التي يرغب بها ضيف الرحمن ومنها
اطلاق المنصه والبوابه الالكترونيه نسرق
وتم اطلاق التطبيق الالكتروني كذلك هذا
التطبيق سيشهد في المرحله القادمه باذن
الله زياده خدمات المتاحه بما يسهل على
الضيف الرحمن كامل مراحل
الاسعار دكتور تعرف انه بعض المعتمرين من
خارج المملكه يعانون مساله ارتفاع الاسعار
تعاملهم مع بعض الشركات ربما في بلادهم
هنا هنا هل هناك اي دور لوزاره الحج
والعمره في معالجه هذه المشكله
فعلا يعني ما تفضلت فيه هو صحيح بسبب
تعامل البعض مع بعض المكاتب السياحيه خارج
المملكه التي تقوم بمغالات الاسعار بشكل
مبالغ فيه وكذلك تقديم بعض الخدمات بدون
تفاصيل او شفافيه لهذا السبب قامت الوزاره
الان باتاحه حجز الباقات بشكل مباشر
للافراد مع تعريف بالاسعار الخدمات من
خلال منصاتها الالكترونيه الشخص الان من
خارج المملكه اذا ما زال يرغب في التعامل
مع
الخارجيين او مكاتب السياحه في دولته هذا
المسار متاح لي ولكن يخضع للرقابه من حيث
كافه الخدمات المقدمه من الشريك السعودي
هذا يتم مراقبته وعرض اسعاره في المنصه
بشكل واضح واذا يرغب في التعاقد مع مباشره
المملكه فان الاسعار يتم عرضها بشفافيه
واضحه وكذلك يتم متابعتها ومراقبتها لضمان
تقديم الخدمه بشكل الصحيح وفي حال وجود اي
مخالفه
تضمن الخدمه المقدمه شكرا لك يا دكتور
عمرو المداح وكيل وزاره الحج والعمره
لخدمات الحجاج والمعتمرين من جده
في الرابعه بعد قليل 100 فارس وفارسه من
اربعين دوله يدشلون بطوله الملك سلمان
للقدره والتحمل في العلا
اهلا بكم من جديد انطلقت في العلا شمال
غرب السعوديه منافسات بطوله كاس خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الدوليه للقدره والتحمل
2023 وذلك وسط منافسه 200 فارس وفارس من
مختلف انحاء العالم يمثلون اربعين دوله
[موسيقى]
شهدت المنطقه الشرقيه في السعوديه اقامه
اول معرضا للكتاب تنظمه هيئه الادب والنشر
والترجمه ضمن مهرجان الكتاب والكراهب او
الكتاب عفوا والقراء ويستمرون معرض
الشرقيه للكتاب حتى الحادي عشر من مارس
الجري يعقد المعرض بشركه ثقافيه مع مركز
الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء
وبمشاركه اكثر من 500 ناشر محلي وعربي
ودولي فضلا عن اقامه نحو 140 فعاليه ضمن
برنامج ثقافيا خاص
معنى من مراسل او معنى من معرض الشرقيه
للكتاب مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصي
عبد الرحمن حياك الله
هذا هو معرض الكتاب اذا في الشرقيه لكن
كان يشوف الاقبال ضعيف
لا بالعكس خالد يعني اهل الشرقيه متعطشين
جدا لهذا المعرض الذي غاب عنهم كثيرا
واخيرا اقيم معرض الشرقيه لكتاب طبعا هذا
المعرض ياتي ضمن مهرجان الكتاب والقراء في
المنطقه الشرقيه الذي يشمل العديد من
الفعاليات يعني الاسبوع الاول كان فعاليات
ثقافيه في ثلاث مواقع الدمام وكرنيش الخبر
وايضا كورنيش القطيف
ثم بدا يوم الخميس قبل يومين معرض الكتاب
لنتحدث اكثر خالد عن هذا المعرض وابرز
الارقام وابرز الفعاليات والبرامج
الثقافيه الموجوده في انضم الي رئيس
التنفيذي لهيئه الادب والنشر تجربه
الدكتور محمد حسن علوان اهلا دكتور محمد
نتكلم بدايه عن مهرجان الكتاب والقراء
ياتي بشكل مختلف لماذا الكتاب والقراء
ولماذا يعني تم تجهيز تجزئه المهرجان جزء
مهرجانات فعاليه بالهواء الطلق وجزء معرض
كتاب
طبعا الكتاب والقران انهم من الطرفين
الاساسيين في هذه العلاقه التاريخيه
الثقافيه التي محورها الكتاب المهرجان
اقيم في عده مواقع كما تفضلت وكان الهدف
منه ان نمحور فعاليات الثقافيه حول هذه
العلاقه ولكن بالتنويع في طبيعه
الفعاليات الثقافيه متنوعه ندائيه وكان
فيها ايضا مسرحيات وكان فيها عروض كوميديا
وكان فيها ايضا
مساحات متاحه لدور النشر والمكتبات لعرض
منتجاتها الثقافيه وايضا للمنتجات الاهالي
اي انها كانت فعاليه اجتماعيه في المقام
الاول
يراد منها ان
ندعو اهالي المنطقه
للاحتفال
بالكتاب وبالقراء وبالمنتج الاساسي الناتج
منهما وهو الكتاب زميلي خالد قبل شوي يقول
الاقبال كانه ضعيف
دكتور يعني كيف شفتوا الاقبال خلال اول
ثلاثه ايام من المهرجان وايضا ابرز الدور
المشاركه اعدادها ابرز الدول المشاركه في
المهرجان لا ما نشوف الرقبه الضعيف عذرا
استاذ خالد
لكن المعرض كبير الحجم مساحات كبيره جدا
او موزعه فيها
دور النشر على اربع قاعات كبرى هناك قاعه
اضافيه اضفناها للمعرض
للاستجابه للطلب العالي من دور النشر
السعوديه والحمد لله المساحات مشغوله منذ
الصباح منذ افتتاح المعرض من الصباح وحتى
اقفال المعرض وعدد الزوار لا يتوقف ان
يعني زياره المعرض
وايضا يعني
المشاركه في انشطه البرنامج الثقافي دكتور
مهرجان الثقافي المصاحب
للمهرجان الاسماك كبيره مهمه
روائيين ايضا كتاب شعراء ايضا شعر نبطي
نتكلم عن ابرز ملامح هذا البرنامج الثقافي
نعم حرصنا في ذلك ان يكون البرنامج ننوع
كما ذكرت واريد ان انتهز هذه الفرصه
واتقدم بالشكر الجزيل للشريك الثقافي
الوحيد لهذا المعرض وهو مركز الملك عبد
العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء الذين قاموا
باعداد البرنامج الثقافي وتكفل بذلك وهو
كما يعني لاحظتم كان على مستوى ما هو
متوقع من اثراء الذين اعتدنا منهم دائما
الابداع والحراك الثقافي الرصين والفاعل
والمؤثر الحمد لله البرنامج في ثلاث ايام
الاولى حظي باقبال كبير من
الزوار وايضا كان هناك ورش عمل يعني
حارسنا انها متنوعه في مجالات مختلفه
وقدموها لنا مركز الملك عبد العزيز
الثقافي العالمي بكل ما يمكن ان نتوقع
منهم من ابداع وحرص على
استيفاء جميع معايير الجوده وتلبيه رغبات
الزوار اخيرا دكتور ايضا لاحظت الطفل له
نصيبه من هذا المعرض له نصيب كبير جدا
ونحن مستمرون في زياده المساحات المخصصه
للطفل في جميع معارض الكتاب في المملكه
لايماننا الكبير بانه الطفل هو
يعني جزء لا يتجزا من حراك الثقافي هو
ايضا مستقبل الثقافه وايضا هناك العديد
مما يمكن ان نقدمه للطفل مما يحوله الى
زائر دائم لمعارض الكتاب باذن الله في
المستقبل
الفعاليات الموجهه للطفل ليست فعاليات
ترفيهيه فقط بل هي فعاليه فعاليات ثقافيه
هادفه الى اكتشاف المواهب الى خلق او خلق
هذه الحاله الابداعيه لدى الطفل بذره
الاستكشاف وايضا
يعني تجسير اللي هو المحتمل بين الطفل
وبين عالم الثقافه بوصفه عالما عالما يعني
فيه الكثير من المتعه شكرا جزيلا دكتور
محمد
خالد يعني كما راينا فعلا معرض متنوع جدا
ومهرجان كبير جدا حفلات موسيقيه ايضا
موجوده طوال ليالي المهرجان اقبال من جميع
الفئات العمريه ايضا من حسن حظ المعرض ان
هذا الاسبوع اسبوع اجازه بالنسبه للطلاب
فالاقبال سيزيد اكثر فاكثر مع مرور الايام
شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
مراسل العربيه من معارض الشرقيه للكتاب
احتفلت العربيه
بعيدها العشرين وسط حضور كبير من موظفيها
الخليينه والمؤسسين ومشاركه ايضا من ضيوف
وصحفيين من مختلف دول العالم العربيه تجدد
عادها في عيدها ال20 على مواصله رسالتها
الاعلاميه
اجواء احتفاليه سادت غرفه اخبار قناه
العربيه روح معنويه عاليه بيعيدها العشرين
عقدان من المهنيه والمثابره وسنوات من
الفخر بالمشاهد والمتابعه الثاقبه حول
العالم
اليوم يوم تاريخي مميز العربيه يوم نتذكر
في كل انجازات العربيه خلال الفتره
الطويله هذه وهي انجازات من اول يوم انطلق
في العربيه انطلقت في قناه قدمت المهنيه
قدمت الموضوعيه قدمت الخطاب الاعلامي
المعتدل
مرحبا بكم في غرفه اخبارنا
الاحتفالات بدات مبكرا مع الساعات الاولى
من اليوم ببرنامج صباح العربيه جمع
ايقونات الماضي والحاضر جنبا الى جنب
لاستحضار لحظاتهم التي لا تنسى
استعدنا شريط ذكرياتنا مع اطلاق النشره
الاولى لقناه العربيه في الثالث من مارس
عام 2003 كنا على الهواء مباشره مع طالب
كنعان واليوم عشنا معه هذه اللحظه مجددا
ما زلنا في حاله نوستالجيا التي رسمت على
وجوه زملائنا داخل قناه العربيه بنبره
صوتهم القوي ومع كل ضربه على اوتار الاطار
جاب سيكينز مهد الطريق لانطلاقه يوم مثير
[موسيقى]
لعشرين سنه نجوم المجتمع من مختلف انحاء
العالم شاركوا العربيه بعيدها العشرين انا
اتابع قناه العربيه منذ عشرين سنه كل سنه
وقناه العربيه القناه الرائده اللي
بتنقللنا اهم الاخبار القناه اللي فيها
جزء من يومياتنا ويا رب عقبال 100 سنه من
النجاح والتنوير اهني قناتنا الرائعه
والاكثر من رائع العربيه مناسبه مرور
عشرين عام على تاسيس التي تمر من هنا
لهما موضع مميز على مدار اليوم زملائنا
الذين وضعوا حياتهم على المحك في سبيل
صناعه القصه الصحفيه لم ننسى تضحياتهم
خسرت قناه العربيه مرسلتها في العراق زميل
اطوار بهجت اضافه الى
زميليعاود مطارده شغفه الاخباري زميون
الصحفي جواد كاظم بعد ان نجى سابقا من
هجوم ارهابي عاد الى شاشتنا وظهر بشكل خاص
مع نجله كريم
وهذه
فعرف انه عندي نشره على الهواء وهذه قلت
له تعال حتى تصدق انه احنا خلف الكاميرا
كان موجود يعني ويراقب التقارير واللقاءات
والاخبار العاجله لا تتوقف لكن في الاثناء
ننتظر دوما عوده زملائنا بسلام من
تغطياتهم في المناطق الساخنه بدايه الحرب
كان في عنا طاقم من كريستيان بيشري مذيعه
والمصور طلال المصري كانوا في اوكرانيا
قبل بدايه الحرب لاعداد بعض التقارير
والمواقف وبديت الحرب وهم موجودين
بالبيدان وقاموا بتقطيع رائع وممتازه
فاستمريت بالتواصل معهم بشكل يومي بشكل
دائم حتى اطمئنينا على وضعهم وتم اخراجهم
لاحقا بعد ما ادوا تغطيه رائعه صحيح
فهذه كانت احدى المواقف الكبيره العاطفيا
اللي اثرها
مواكبه التقنيات العالميه على مدار
الاعوام العشرين الماضيه كانت دوما ما
يميز العربيه لتظهر لكم بصوره عصريه وبحله
تلبي تطلعات مشاهديها تكنولوجيا
ساعدتنا كتير انه نمر بهذه المرحله الصعبه
ونطلع في الشكل الجديد للعربيه اللي هو
عباره عن عشرين سنه وفعلا الشكل اللي
موجود حاليا
بيعطي
قيمه للعشرين سنه اللي مرت من من القناه
بانتهاء اليوم اجتمعت عائله عربيه لتعزيز
هذه الخطوه البعيده التي قطعناها في سماء
الاعلام لنستعد لانطلاقه جديده نحو مستقبل
واعد وفي الذاكره ماض نعتز به كل العمل
هذا بجهودكم انتم باخلاصكم بعملكم انا جدا
جدا فخور اني اكون زميل معكم اليوم وجدا
فخور في العمل معكم اشوف كل العمل
والتضحيات والعمل المستمر وان شاء الله
عشرين سنه قادمه شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
ورجعت الامريكيه لتهديدات ايران البنتاجون
يؤكدوا على مواجهه الميليشيات التابعه
لظهرا
المملكه العربيه رئيس الوزراء العراقي
يؤكدوا للعربيه ان السعوديه دوله محوريه
والتاسعه لتكوين النظام اقليمي مستقر
اعتقادات لسوق المحاماه في السعوديه رفض
لممارسات الوصايه ودعوات لتطوير اداء
المحامي
واستعدادات المكثفه لموسم العمره في رمضان
وثمانيه ملايين معتمر قدموا للسعوديه خلال
سبعه اشهر
شرقيه تشهد اول معرض للكتاب مائه الناشرين
والفعاليات الثقافيه في اكسبو ظهران
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]